listing at Yoga
will has to do food all right here we
are today we are chatting with filmmaker
John Yost thank you for joining us today
John time thank you for having us that's
pretty cool it's really neat that on
your technology so yeah there were you
know I don't know we're just jumping
into the fray here as well we had a
chance to do this with Lucas McNelly a
couple days ago and you know you know in
terms of what we're doing right now with
the release of goodbye promise we just
need something quicker we need to be
able to get some content online quicker
and so we're going to see if this can
save us some time and also help us sort
of share our efforts and what we're
doing and share our story sure sure and
yeah Lucas was telling me about trying
to kind of come up like a town meeting
type of auction type of telephone feel
and he was talking about this and I
didn't know it kind of existed was
talking more about it I was like that's
really like doping you guys are taking
time off your thing to help in on as
well Jen jack is all about just yeah I
just Lucas brother Jan as well how is
that going how are you enjoying this
kind of this kind of quick and you know
right to the point where connecting
audience that stuff or is it is it that
you finding its clunky or what do you
what's working or not I shouldn't ask
you because I'm sorry I won't ask wide
open conversation but obviously we've
done something really ambitious with the
release of goodbye promise and we're
trying to be as open and enter and as
transparent with the process as we can
so that all independent artists can can
learn from just you know bypassing
traditional means and going right to the
audience and so no this is great for us
to take an opportunity to speak with
various people that we respect you know
get a chance to have open conversations
get some feedback some input from from
you guys and just sort of move this
whole story along so yeah we're totally
open we're not you know this isn't us
running the show this is just this is
just down and talking about this whole
adventure of ours guys had a set of
thing that Gregory like what that lost a
that enjoyed that quite a bit like I
mean I like his his take on things
usually is very just like just do it
don't like just I like that attitude it
was cool it was just like it was instant
you guys were right there just talking
he aight cuz i know he's idaho and you
guys are LA on New York so it's kind of
cool that we can all just like Lucas is
a boutique called the year without rent
it's kind of all gated as smaller which
was pretty pretty dope it's pretty
pretty nice that world cup getting
closer and working together even though
we live he decided the world or the
country so its beauty today because I
had to go walk somewhere to the store
just really quickly and I was like it's
so weird to think that even though where
we live it's such a small sort of town
feel in LA and it's actually sort of a
time work in some sense um but that we
can just be behind our computers and
make like a ripple out there in the
world and it's like the most surreal
thing like a to me just it's fascinating
how you sent home behind our computers
with our pets around us and you know
whatever the TV on or whatever it is
kind of make this ripple and then people
in in upstate New York and see it and
people in in Idaho and then you know
someone in wherever you know New Zealand
can see it so it's it's fascinating it's
actually terrifying to a little bit yeah
like everything you say can be seen by
anyone we were like I'm just I was
clicking the terms of whatever security
for the thing it's like just you know
that anyone could see this is like
alright sounds good to me I mean yeah
it'sit's it's good and bad and i think
that i think this technology is slowly
being used in productive ways i said
just someone rapidly talking to each
other about you know what they ate or
some like that i mean it easier to have
that no matter what but i think it's
it's nice to see people who are driven
using it for something purposeful that
make sense yeah you know it just has a
heads up john i did i just want to point
it out there's some sort of like audio i
don't know if it's the headphones but
they're such audio kick i don't know if
it's like when you move or
the headphone I can't tell if the
headphones or not but we're going to me
I'm gonna try that Oh quick you hear me
yeah yeah that better still hear it it's
like a like a like there's traffic in
the background I think it's better now
though John yeah those animals let's try
without bit maybe maybe there's a
there's a yoga instructor in the
background doing yoga come here you
what's it hot no cuz thats good shoes i
was there i like camera yeah no no
nothing that he says huh she's all
sweaty she says it's all sweaty all
right are we good is that better yeah I
think that's better I think I got it oh
you know so lets you know sometimes it's
helpful you know to sort of dig into the
stories of others and then that gives us
sort of an avenue to reveal more about
what we're doing so helped take us to
where you are right now John are are you
it sounds like you're getting ready to
launch your own Kickstarter campaign we
have that right clothes yeah I mean we
just we did and then so I've been
writing this film for a while for about
a year and then we shot a short film
version of like some of what's happening
kind of like a bit of a Methos or kind
of like a back story to the feature and
that went really well and we finished it
up and there was a art exhibit and all
these kind of facets of the story that
we put out there and then we we started
a Kickstarter about 11 days ago and in
that 11 days from the beginning of that
till about two days ago things trained
changed drastically with the film in the
sense that it was clear that it was a
film that needed to be shot over about
20 25 to 30 days in about five different
shoots over the course of the entire
year instead of an 18 to 20 in September
we were going to shoot on September 15th
and egg was the first shooting day and
it became very clear that that was not
healthy way to make the film it's not
what the film needed and I made the
executive decision as being the director
obviously and talk about all the other
folks and and they said let's let's do
it how we
we know it'll be done the best you know
for 25,000 how can we make a
post-apocalyptic film from another
universe but that little bit of money
it's we got to do it like in stages and
you know really work at each five to six
days shoot and also if we're going to do
that then we'll why not use the season
so we made that decision and we looked
at our Kickstarter campaign and said
well this doesn't fit anymore so I
canceled it and I restarted it and
hopefully the folks who were already
part of it will be part of it again and
we lower the amount because we have
hopefully some investment and then we
have the Kickstarter itself and with
that we can fund the first you know
three-fourths of the shooting and then
go back and say here's what we've done
here is what we have um check it out
help us again and and also get more
important people involved because i had
this is the first 1i had wrong
kickstarter wise and it was very
interesting how everyone was really
supportive on stuff and all of a sudden
went from like nine hundred friends on
facebook to you know a thousand like
overnight was like and then new people
were coming on meeting new people into
the exciting so i kinda keep that going
all year long and i don't want to just
take a chunk and leave I've already made
a mistake and disappear for two years I
make a film just finishing it now the
last month with two years ago I'm people
like oh where is that movie so it was
cuff necessity for the film for the
campaign but also really kind of
exciting to then hopefully doing this
for a long time we'll be talking with my
our audience and I started getting
excited that this could be the reality
for me as a filmmaker is that on every
film i make over the course of the year
and I involve people over the course of
that you know but shooting it and then
you make it even further and you're
always kind of involved it's new for me
it's a guess this but maybe this was
incredibly exciting out of other folks
watching or like not so new for us but
it's really neat that's really enjoyable
to be doing something they don't like it
a short film and then getting a reaction
out of it people responding to it so
that's what we did so great now we've
relaunched it three hours ago
already a twenty percent so hey so I
mean Lee know it's gonna use gold but
yeah we're trying to beso de Jong I'm
wondering when you first launched it
what were the initial things you were
doing to get it beyond family and
friends he said you had many friends on
Facebook and then I grew so what was
your strategy to get it beyond that
point that was just persistence and
actually that that's it's funny because
that actually that portion hadn't
started yet so for the first kind of
five or some days we were still kind of
in that facebook and twitter and local
network of friends and family and all
that stuff was being put in place like a
press releases were going out talking to
you to you folks like other people about
hey we should talk about our films and
so that was starting to get going and
then this thing happened with the film's
the content itself so hopefully it's
kind of a seamless thing that that
people are too jarred because it's it's
it looks exactly the same but it's for a
different amount and then that all that
all that hard work in getting out to an
audience beyond just my friends and
family thinks of that are going to kick
in and I just kind of go from there I
mean we'll see I try my best foot so
that I guess I don't other than the
strategies of thinking about the film
has a shape note or sacred heart singers
in it I've been talking to that
community the film has a a lot about
Cyril John Cyril technology so I'm
talking that community post-apocalyptic
a little bit sci-fi talking to that
community and music is a very big
important part so talking to that
community and that again those are kind
of all been started and continue to keep
moving but I where we'll go it I hope I
get to talk to even even more folks up
are you of the school of thought that
don't reach out to mainstream because
David and I debate this all the time I
don't premature I like to do things
right away and just let's get the ball
moving and David likes to kind of wheat
and then feels people should wait until
there's more momentum behind their
campaign is that is that you're feeling
too um I mean yeah it's a good question
because
before no I would like when I they when
I first started making films I just yeah
how are you and and and create momentum
that I would think would just go through
and it you know would hit a brick wall
and then slowly learning like I can be
hanging them all from up with it's just
let's do it let's get excited and get in
that that direction and then but if I
want to get something done from that
energy then I have to be like oh just be
a little bit more i guess that calculate
that sounds terrible but or just just
you know plan just be like okay i know
i'm not going to take it there right now
because that's not something that
they're going to be interested in and
it'll have no blood no connection to it
but later when i get to a certain point
and you know a certain actor maybe comes
on board then this other person and that
other group would be more engaged and
i'll go to them men but i mean i think
it's it's it's tough i think is that the
fine line between because I do this
because I have fun because it's
enjoyable because it's awesome because I
you know it's like the thing from that
almost famous movie were where they
legally careers characters like didn't
we do this to like not be responsible
like this is where rock and roll this is
like filmmaking to rock and roll but
it's also like you know when you don't
have a manager at Capitol Records you
and your you know playing dive bars you
got to be you got to have a plan too so
it's a tough fine line I think I mean
but I do yes a long way around yes I do
think about that didn't used to but I do
now for sure no John can you help us
understand the numbers of the two can't
the difference between the two campaigns
can can you sort of highlight the
initial funding goal and how many did
you say i think was 11 days you said how
close you came to like how much money
did you actually raise and then now the
new campaign how much money are you
going for here on and I guess you're
only three hours in so it's hard to say
whether new keep of jumped on board yet
but can you just compare contrast the
two campaign that the total sure sure
sure yeah um we were and you know Lucas
was given me a hand with the campaign
and
we looked at our my network and other
networks and were like look to the
budget to it was just about that and we
said 28,000 is what we we could do it
for and that was and that is the budget
that's I mean these taken away and perks
take it away that's the budget right
there is about 24 and it's like one of
those things like you know last few it's
like he I could do it for 24 but I I've
really had like you know not pay anybody
I could do it for 14 but I just I got to
a point was like I don't wanna do that
anymore like I want to do it I want to
pay everyone probably I don't want to
skimp so much anymore I want to want to
do things right way so it's like now
where did that happen it has to be and
then when the film changed it became
very clear that it can be done it
actually ends up saving money because
we're not getting everyone in one space
for 20 days and and like I did the math
and all of a sudden you know it was
translating to about twelve hundred
dollars a day for shooting and it's down
the like nine hundred and so it's like
by breaking that up it made more sense
for four and also because you know I
rely on people that day jobs you know
people that are not you know in the you
know like dp's in the industry and
actors are industry but they also have
things I have to do and so as soon as
that was back then you know that was
decided on we said all right well you
know realistically how much is that
first half or two-thirds of shooting and
getting us to a point how much is that
we need him over 8,500 because of them
how we're breaking it down we save I
think almost four grand and because it's
only halfway through then it's about 12
and it's about 850 8500 so we put that
down and you know I we had already
raised about four and a half so that
hopefully will come back just because
it's a lot of good friends and family
and patron saints as you guys probably
know you have your patron saints of the
family or friends that have helped you
out hopefully I'll come back and then
that will put us at
up forty percent and then it's really
just then it has I think legs and I mean
Lucas we're talking sometimes it's just
that last place politician doesn't get
looked at as someone who you'd even vote
for but then if you're at forty percent
some I've got a shot I mean you know
again we were talking about parents like
you know you have to think about this so
I don't like thinking about this stuff
because I like making movies and I like
like I move money I just hate money but
I realize it's a part what we have to do
and um the most exciting I guess aspect
like i said is reaching an audience and
talking to people that was really cool
um but you know sometimes it's just like
oh I have to I have to think in
percentages and I have to think well
alright well forty percent right now is
better than eleven percent because then
that game you know I mean like so if I
want to fund this and I want to make
this film I kind of have to it can't be
a point of pride it has to be a point of
do I want to make this movie or not and
so I was like let's scrap it lets its
confess our mistakes and everything on
and where we're headed with it and let's
redo it I don't know I don't know if
that works for a lot of people or how
that that ends up translating I mean I
think that there is a in our industry
especially there's a little bit of this
kind of like perfect examples of budget
people don't want to say well yeah I
made it for 10 grand and that you know
like I've run into people were like well
how much was the budget really like oh
ten grand I was like how much did you
put online to be there like a more than
a half and it's just like I mean I
understand the need for that but at the
same time it's like we can just be
honest I guess and you know me like it's
in my perfect society in the perfect
world and that would actually happen but
it's out that long story short I guess
sorry you like that sometimes can you
speak a little bit more on this decision
to scrap a Kickstarter campaign in the
in the middle of it because you know
that's something they care and I are you
know we haven't heard of that sort of
thing happening that often where
someone's going to sort of strap one
campaign it takes so much effort just to
get just to get that ball rolling you
know and so here you are
you know how much time I mean like the
days go by and it was just something I
was weighing on you for days or was it
just a matter of just a couple hours in
one day like you talk a little bit more
about it yeah i mean it on friday i
think we made the decision to change the
structure of the filmmaking and so that
it was like all right well let's look at
then the fundraising so what's so we
changed this as look at that and I mean
frankly I like working hard and I like
having a certain amount of pressure but
the pressure was weighing on me to the
point like the all-or-nothing thing kind
of got to me I mean I still like the
all-or-nothing thing because I
understand how it motivates people to to
to pledge and things like that but it
was getting I was having panic attacks
before honestly I was uh I found myself
driving to work and just bursting into
tears it's the weirdest thing like I'm
not like that I'm not normally a sand
dude but just because I want to do this
film so bad and then all of a sudden
like I was like what did i do I put you
know the film has just changed and then
I put everything in this one basket and
and then I realized I don't even need
the whole basket and then I was just
like all right so what do I need to do
and so we have with so friday and then
today so that's what saturday sunday
monday for four days we switched over
and they improved it and i can't see the
other wanted and contacted all our
backers and said you know this is going
to make us this is going to make a
better film the long run I mean we're
definitely going to have to refund raise
next June in order to finish we can get
if we clear our goal and some of the
other funding that I have put together
we can shoot the first three
installments out of four so that's I
kind of did I guess I took a gamble is
like I'd rather get that done and get
that done properly and then like come to
people more like here I have I have some
of this film I filmed and because we got
a good response to the short film and
this is like you know what do you think
now can you help us out a little bit
more and so that's kind of that was the
decision
or the idea of like all right let's do
that and yeah Lucas haven't heard of
that either he was asleep well I guess I
imagine people have done that before and
and I've talked to people before too and
people have said like well what do you
do do you say I didn't get the amount
that I wanted to carry it all the way
through and and then the Kickstarter
doesn't doesn't go through and then just
say like you know what or do you daft
halfway through or like and I guess
there was a little bit in the back of my
head that I was doing something wrong in
our in our community like I was like
like people like you know the imaginary
person like right here me like that's
wrong doing it wrong no one does it like
that like all right I'm shut up yeah so
I was like no I think that it felt right
like sense then no panic attacks no
crime excited back to normal back to me
the way I make films and so maybe that's
just more of like trying to figure out
how it works for you personally I don't
know like I don't again like you guys
have probably talked with a lot of folks
about campaigns and stuff like that I've
had you know the pleasure talking with
Gregory about a few things and Zack
Porter's being about a few things and
Lucas obvious what I think things and
I've done I've done that I think
actually first make you guys I talk to
you guys you're having about some of
that stuff that campaign stuff so it's
you know I think there is a little bit
of in my opinion in one-size-fits-all
not from from you guys but from like you
go to out near nets and you'll see that
and then you get down to the reality you
start talking to folks like you and
Lucas was it well not we can just we can
do this ever we want so I mean that you
know I think it'll evolve to I think
Kickstarter will eventually evolve
something else good hopefully it is
equals good that's right sorry you wind
me up there again and I get talking um
that that was that good that's great i
guess i guess i'll jump in here oh yeah
yeah you know first off i think it's i
think it's really clever that
you're sort of taking this large bowl
which is really massive and really
weighing on you I think I think it's
great that you know even though it's
probably a hard decision to make I think
it's great to sort of break it down take
the pressure off you put you in a
position to actually do the work you
know I mean like that that's that
sometimes I can just be the toughest
thing is just just getting into the work
so I think you're empowering yourself I
think you'll be able to show results you
know the journey and the thing I love
that you're doing i love the fact that
you're communicating you're being you're
being clear about like this is what we
did like this is what's wrong with it
now this is what we're trying to do and
you're being a front you're saying you
know what we're going to raise money but
this isn't going to be the full amount
we're gonna have to come back and do
this again but at least when we come
back the next time we're going to have
something to show for it so i really i
really like that plan of attack cool
thanks man I think that I think deep
down we all just want to make the film I
mean I don't I mean I do know people who
just want to say that making the phone
but i think that i think everyone here
on this phone calls work really hard to
make that film will always work really
hard to make that film it's quite a
parent watching some of your thumb
already that it's just like you guys are
like just as in the trenches with
everyone else try to make a movie and do
it but you're not talking will do it but
you do need some people like on that's
going to make a film I'm going to make a
fountain but then there's a people like
us and Lucas and some other folks that
just go and make them and so then it
comes down to its like you put them up
there you know you put a barrier in my
way and then I just it's a problem like
art making to me it's just the is
problem solving is making choices it's
all art is and it's exciting as hell so
I just kind of at first I kind of came
up against it like oh you know and then
I just like this is just another problem
solving and what's going to get the film
eight let's do this now like so but I
mean I like to think that anyone anyone
out there listening and you guys would
have done the same thing if you want to
make the movie and we want to get it
done you're going to get it gotta get it
so we should talk about your I'm kind of
Pumped let me talk about kick-starting
something I'm really pumped that you
guys are you guys are basically in that
kick-starting but like um it's like a
pre-sales mixed with like a crowdfunding
of a release and that's really dome and
I really like that a lot because yeah I
wouldn't hear more about that actually
sorry if I switched rails on its real
quick but I'm excited about that we'll
talk about Ren's echo karen has
something she wants to jump in with oh
yeah just real you keep the incentives
the same you the first campaign you
launch did you change it up at all did
you I did because I people were really
responding to him and I quite like them
there's like video journals for complete
you know where he had a thousand backers
so that you know let me go shoot a
two-minute because that basically they
made that day so shoot to a minute feat
the film on that day happening um
shooting with John they can come on
shooting with John which is my show on
filmmaker magazine and then those are
some of the big ones but even the small
ones I've been doing an Instagram thank
you like on the spot like where everyone
is putting a thank-you kharap and front
and taking a picture of me or whoever
this weekend my friend was up in New
York he's an abortion I'm just being
like it like a really cool connection
through Instagram and through networking
and the movies and films and subway so I
I was pretty happy with it I I haven't
heard any complaints about it but I do
have a few like a two or three kind of
fun ones that I'm going to like how at
least two weeks a week towards the end
kind of like there's a there's a main
character is a girl and a kitten in the
film and there's a website i don't know
if you're seeing kitties and titties
it's like one of my favorite websites in
the world i'm being a little cheeky but
it's a it's a good 1i not going to do
that i'm just going to say four by five
postcards of kate with the kitten
because I mean that's just awesome you
know like so little things like that I
just gave it away well yeah like so
little things like that but um I did
keep the same in center stone hopefully
people like them you don't please tell
me let me know I liked it I liked it so
so you say you've been able to take a
look at our efforts with the campaign
you know what more runs through your
mind what questions do you have um I
think the only I mean I the only
question is is it I guess my question is
I don't know IndieGoGo very well is it a
time thing cuz i think it says like 30
some days did you set that or is that
can you can you just like set up an
open-ended amount of time and just use
it as a free sale engine / crowdfunding
or do you have to be like knows it like
Kickstarter like 30 days right or that's
it i think i think with indiegogo I mean
you know this is something where we felt
like I had to be 30 days you know you
know we just felt like if do I learned
it longer I wanted to 30 days everyone
in line um no just just I guess just
over time and you know I just feel like
if your message is going to get out you
know the internet move so fast that if
you have something you know you don't
need to draw it out you know and and
here and I know in addition to film
courage in addition everything else
we're trying to do you know we still
have day jobs so we're trying to we're
trying to do all this we're still trying
to you know you know have an income
coming in or whatever so you know so
it's hard to say like let's do this for
six to the straw it's on for 60 days is
it it's really not conducive to our
lives so so no 30 is really just us
pushing ourselves to the limit yeah I
think with IndieGoGo I i think the
limits 120 I think with Kickstarter the
limits 19 I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
Miami I thought I think 90 days on
Kickstarter I think 120 on an IndieGoGo
I'm not totally certain out i can't i
can't verify that I just I just have a
feeling with that's what the numbers
might be but I i think i think get away
with at least 90 days though
think so yeah I mean once that 30 days
is up what are you going coming because
I'm looking at what you guys are doing
so far you're getting a good response so
you'll have a certain amount are you
worried obviously going to continue to
sell it or what is that like a kickstart
to to distribution or does that kind of
I guess that's my question is like what
do you do once the 30 days are over and
obviously here is still sell your movie
or are you going to look at like
festivals this is kind of a preview for
folks or yeah you know it's interesting
because this this this sort of launch
you know as far as we know it's been
confirmed by Adam Shack Nick over at
IndieGoGo where no one has really taken
this initiative to do this before so
this is new territory we're not asleep
committed to one thing or another I mean
we're hoping they did well enough with
the release so that we can have it you
know have some money in place for for
maybe a limited run on DVDs you know and
eventually we'd like to get the film on
other platforms but certainly the plan
is at the end of 30 days then we take
the film down offline so we're giving
people this this limited window that
we've created through indiegogo and then
this is sort of our first window of
release and we've decided to bypass film
festivals we've decided to bypass
distributors and with film festivals and
and that sort of thing it's hard to say
whether they're going to want to screen
our film or not you know it you know
typically they want the world premiere
of your film we're going right to the
people people all over the world are
seeing the film we're creating our own
bus it is hard to say I can offer one
interesting Tippett right now that I
don't think you've shared yet is after
we did have one a one-week run in Los
Angeles at the downtown on a Penant yeah
Lucas said some about that consider you
actually I think you would tell me about
like briefly at Mardi or one of those
guys was like yeah they're gonna have
like a week run and then they're gonna
try something really cool I don't know
what it was I think they knew the
secrets ahead of time so Steve Jobs yeah
you were never expecting the LA Times
Review know that they're really cool
that they've really floored us to get
into big basically a near-perfect review
in LA Times and what's funny is we've
gotten a several other reviews since the
LA Times and none of them have been you
know quite the glowing review that we
got another times we've gotten sort of
like subpar reviews on other platforms
that are smaller that you know that
don't have the viewership but it's great
that the film really connected with with
who we really needed it to but because
of LA Times we decided like hey you know
what maybe there's more of an audience
for this film maybe we should really try
to try to look at new york and see if we
can get a theater there Oh to run it and
then maybe get a change LEM saw the New
York Times The New Yorker and all the
New York media and so we tried for about
a month and a half or you know to
mid-july we tried that whole time to see
if we can get York and Austin and
internships San Francisco and Seattle
and Karen and Gregor were just they were
on the phone they were on the email just
hitting everybody I'm trying to get one
of these theaters to offer us a deal we
weren't able to make that happen but
since the release of the online our sins
since our online release Gregor
contacted one of the theaters in New
York and now they've taken a look at the
film and now they're interested in
screening it which one is it which one
are you maybe can't say oh yeah I have
to say it so I was going to say it's too
bad that that rerun i think is pretty
much gone or is on its way out rerun was
pretty cool my main actor Frank Mosley
showed his movie hold there really nope
spots curated by the guy who actually is
starting a believe a video a video store
Brooklyn took one all over that was kind
of feeling so this is but there's
something like that but I don't you
don't have to tell me now but actually
when we're done here email me because I
might have one you can go to all right
no one that you guys could totally
screen out for a week in Brooklyn and
get definitely gives you the review so
but put that into the mix but that we
were in contact with the rerun we were
weird about Aaron hellas and it did fall
through so we were very close to make it
happen and that's where we continue to
hold out hope
yeah but that one that particular one
fell through for us so what cuz I think
they're done right i mean i think
they're finished they're just not
finished like in a bad way but i think
they close the theater and or something
am I wrong I could be wrong hey we're
all here that way but you know where
yeah I smart you know we don't York's
yeah New York's close ish I mean like
the glow I'm going to see samsara on
friday with Ron Frick in attendance QA
that's probably like the coolness of New
York being by that's pretty much to me
that's the level of awesomeness of
having your nearby I go see that hi you
guys are in LA man love LA John I'm
wondering what what do you think we
could do to help um bush Jack
marchetti's campaign along you know
we're racking our brains um yeah I'm
racking my brain oh I don't understand
it man like he's going blind he's
cooking well I was like so my wife just
joke around I was like I should tell him
it's going slightly over time
because i'm drinking too much or
something like I mean like he has a
little gym he is going blind like I
don't know like um yeah I don't know man
why would we think because I think it's
a great story I mean the only thing i
can i can think in my head that people
are like oh is that it's a new our film
now I mean a lot of people either don't
know what that is or they don't think
it's done correctly or I told Lucas
maybe seeing the script cuz that's one
thing like i'm gonna i'm going to get i
was planning on giving anyways and i'm
going to talk to Lucas later i'm going
to give while we're while we're doing
right then and there but i would being
someone who was doesn't know him at all
maybe just seen this script i mean like
putting putting those loops around it
and you know what do they call those
when you're getting a festival or like
basically putting an award on it the
project greenlight I mean it means some
things some people but I don't
I don't know anything about those
scripts the only movie i've ever seen
that came out of project greenlight was
that movie feast and that thing was
insane it was just you know talking
about the animals that the creatures
that had sex with everyone it was the
weirdest movie I've ever seen in my life
and so that's all i've seen so like I
mean I'm kind of dying to see the script
I mean I'll get because you know Lucas
is a friend and this kids going blind
and he seems to really care but maybe
for some folks that might help them like
a script reading your ski I love like
and what do you guys think I'm a
bi-monthly mark I think the script is
available on the Kickstarter page and we
haven't read the script we're just so
out by the story itself that you know
literally like we've stopped pushing our
own campaign which is you know it's at
our campaign is probably as ambitious as
ever as as any campaign ever and we
decided to just put that on hold because
we care so much about this story that
we're pushing this thing all the way
through Friday to see if we can get him
to his goal and then we'll go back and
work on our campaign so yeah so we're
just hustling as much as we can behind
the scenes we're engaging as many people
as possible and then care and sent out
probably like a thousand emails by now
to all kinds of people that we're
connected to and other media
organizations so you know we're doing
part of it yeah and we're trying to take
the the isight ankle not just the
filmmaking angle and so we reach out to
a few it was like the National
Federation for the blind and things like
that not asking them for money but just
maybe they can share it with their
audience but that was just today so we
haven't heard anything back but yeah you
know yeah what do you guys I need so
quickly the next year's in my pic so I
think this is something quite new I mean
like I keep saying pre-sales so
obviously like I'm bringing it to
something that has been done before and
it's but it's not really like that and
then you guys are trying something new
with with that kind of platform and this
may be just be beyond what you guys are
doing and inform a kind but what do you
guys think is the future this is this
sorry excuse me I got distracted my wife
Howard is just she's angry we just
closed here or go around close it or
uploaded our homeless a no no its pocket
doors but yeah I made a mistake of
setting up right in the middle of
everything anyways yeah just want
but look to you what do you think is the
future of it I mean like is it just
going to be we're all going to keep
trying to push it in the general
direction or I mean I guess your
thoughts I'm interested to hearing from
you guys because you guys are so kind of
entrenched within you talking to a lot
of people on your you're kind of in the
thick of it what is the feeling and
words headed was the feeling of where
it's at and and you know is this is the
is us having to get bust our butt to get
a guy who's going blonde and make a
movie like a sign of something like
what's going on I guess maybe I'm
putting in a spot i hope i'm not but um
you know I think you know I think sort
of the idea of what we're doing is is
what you know more more independent
filmmakers need to do you know it as we
looked at sort of the distribution
options that we had in front of us for
our film you know to be honest that the
options are really really limited you
know a lot of the options you know they
don't they don't they don't really
contain the punch that we need to really
really need from you know from the
options you know like if you go if you
go to Iraq the film festivals it's like
it's so difficult it's so challenging to
actually hit it one of the large compact
like you need to get it to one of the
big film festivals and I was realize
early or talk about like that world that
world premiere like like ARMA it's like
it's a festival of film it shouldn't
really have requirement if it's not so
if you're not about money and you're
about films then that's in my
opinion then you should be like this is
a great film oh it premiered somewhere
while we can't show it's just it's it's
I think it's BS but that's it would
continue yeah I'm agreement yes
yeah it's just there's just so many you
know arm anything is this there's just
so much uncertainty there you know
certainly there's a lot of there's a lot
of advantages there's a lot of pillars
there's so much in gain from the
experience of it all but but starting
off on that quest nothing's really
guaranteed you know that there's the
whole the people the argument you hear
the most is that this is a way to find
the audience and in fact the way I look
at it is is there's like an unlimited
audience online that's just waiting for
content you know and so yeah you know I
get you know just by going any other
route it's like you're just you're
taking this scarce path forward you know
you're only allowing this small group of
people to see it or have exposure to it
and you're not unite you know we wanted
to just get rid of that we just want to
try to create and see if we can just
create a little small snowball and sort
of just push it forward and see how much
momentum we can gain and that's sort of
the beauty with what youtubers are doing
you know that they're putting content
they're making it available they're not
hiding the work you know I mean like
sometimes filmmakers know you've put so
much time and energy into the work and
and you know you're hoping to be
discovered you're hoping that this film
vessel takes you're hoping that this
distributor finds it it's kind of like
you're waiting for a miracle it's always
just been a challenge you know because
they're not the other front there's the
all the all the places where maybe you
could get the exposure netflix and hulu
and all that stuff that stuff's not
guaranteed either you know so it's hard
to get onto those platforms for smaller
films and oh you know so you were kind
of stuck you know so when we're looking
at our options were like what can we do
to just make it simply easy to get it in
front of our audience so that they can
access it really easily and then if they
do like it they have to be at the
ability to share it you know it's cool
being proactive it's me you guys just
took a proactive approach and just said
let's do it let's get it done as well
and I think that that's kind of the
coolest thing about it to me that's the
coolest thing about it is that I don't
have to wait for anyone anymore I could
just be proactive I don't know you guys
you guys have had that experience but
yeah it's almost like
you know like you realize you're like oh
well you know my life in America is you
know it was okay and then you see
something like like riot being in
prison for you know basically
questioning the Kremlin a lot of stuff
like that and I put in jail for two
years like that doesn't really happen
here that's pretty awesome that that
doesn't happen here and then so it's
like the kind of thing with the
independent film you're like you look
back in like a 90's and 80's like you
couldn't make a film and just put it on
the internet and then I think sometimes
Senate cynics and cynicism takes over
and we forget that I think and we forget
how awesome it is just even be able to
do that I think we're still in my
opinion were filled with the arm
flailing bit part of it not not not mean
collectively we like a whole group like
the whole thing I think it's so new I
mean I remember time when there was an
Internet I was in high school so you
know that's not too long ago so like
we're we're new to this whole thing and
but I think that kind of positive like
proactive approach is much better than
people sitting back and being like yeah
man its network it's not doing when I
thought it would it's just can't get on
board with that book sorry I just made
it about me i didn't know i think it's
wide open about the internet i was just
telling dave about today i was just
funny just to see this to kind of be in
the same town you were in for me where
there was no internet at that time and
things were just much different and then
now just be in that same town and the
same buildings are all there but this
world has completely changed and now so
much is in the power of our own hands
and like I said it's almost scary
because you can make this ripple across
the world by the click of your mouse and
it's it's it's exhilarating and it's
terrifying at the same time yeah we all
look back one day and be like whoa first
won't be like Oh what did we what were
we doing but at the same time lost we
like we were we were doing it we were
trying something new and you know it'll
come along and it'll go through several
different things but we may look back at
this time like an 80s haircut be like
oh right yeah it's selling but at least
we gave at least we got the haircut and
at least we tried it and I think that
that's what's exciting about that was
actually the I think the least favorite
thing in mind doing kind of what you
guys are doing like reaching out and
having a cup of play so you know a site
and kind of just putting your voice out
there is going to do that like I'm
filmmaker magazine you get really really
negative people that are just kind of
like just like really man i mean like
we're not saving lives here so like just
chill out like you know we're all trying
something new and take it so incredible
i mean i take filmmaking seriously but
not to the point where you know I it
ruins your day or something you know I
guess I guess it's just like there's you
just have to be like beats be positive i
don't know i guess that's but i'm not
that sounds incredibly corny man but
like best like I said rock and roll and
I'm doing this for fun so let's imma be
responsible but I'm doing it for fun
well I was just watching this interview
with John sales and Maggie Renzi and
they were talking about John Sayles was
saying something like when things change
you have to either sort of change with
them or draw that line in the sand and
say nope this is this is where I'm not
moving you know and there's people that
don't even use email to this day because
it's like oh no no I don't you know I
don't go there but you know I think
anytime there's this new wave of
whatever it is I was just reading
something about how when talkie films
came out that like a lot of actors were
very hesitant about doing them because
they didn't like their their voice or
they had an accent or something and it
ruined their careers so don't worry yeah
yes Stan right sailrite that my what I
didn't see that movie until I was 31
years of age thanks to my wife yeah
there's like very like this like I don't
want to do this man I don't want to this
is this this is a change and its like I
mean you know sometimes you like my
opinion sometimes you want to have some
footing like I can't make work or make
decisions when the whole brownish
shifting I need some cons
or something that I'm just going to
again like art making me is making
decisions or making choices need to make
some constant choices and then allow
things be just to be what they are but I
think that anybody that anyone I would
go from cast to humans we just you know
change sometimes just need a little
little time to to deal with it and I
understand it at the same time though if
we all do it together then it's there's
a bit of a safety blanket I guess like
if we're all changing together all
trying new things and we're not making
at the end of the world and we're not
relying billion dollar companies on the
flip of a new idea then it's okay to try
this stuff and why are we so that was
another thing with us John I mean you
know to be honest you know I mean our
film is really small you know we started
shooting it we didn't even have a proper
microphone and out so we didn't even
have like four proper sound you know
there was no there was no money it was
just literally a camera an idea and just
sort of going out and filming umm so so
that's kind of where we started from so
it's just like when you have this small
little film you just we just want to
have you know put it in a position so
people can access it no and so and then
on the other extreme like with the
studio system you know they have the
capital they have the power to really
roll out their films where they can just
sort of bombard us with their message
and they're willing to take those
massive losses in theatrical knowing
that at some time and all the other
platforms that the movie will come back
around and they'll make their money and
so you know we can't afford to do that
on our level the thing that we do have
is we have speed you know with with the
internet you know we have an ability you
know to just give it out to people right
away and share it and if you look at
what the studios are doing over time
they're trying to collapse that window
more and more you know they're trying to
have it so that when they spend those
big marketing dollars that people are
going to be able to access their film
right away and there's that fight going
on right now between the studios
in the theaters the theaters don't want
that window to close in terms of how
soon they can go on to those other
markets so that's what the studios are
trying to do it and they do this better
than anyone else and then here we are as
independent filmmakers thinking we can
compete in that world when we don't have
any money we don't have the resources
and so but if we're smart about it and
if we just do what they're trying to do
but they're restricted to do because the
theaters won't let them and so that was
also part of our thinking in terms of
let's just go right let's just go right
to it and just and just use use the
speed use the quickness that we do have
access to write on it I was having lunch
with a friend of mine the other day and
it's funny I look back on it now I
wasn't thinking about it until we
changed the structure of the film coming
up but I was saving him and he's like
I'm making this feature and I'm doing
here and doing there I'm like did now
you know just just take it and just do
it all at once and he just looked thing
he's like we're not Holly so I could do
ever the I want I'm like he's right
I could do whatever I want to and and
and then like I heard that the back of
my head when I on Friday when I made
that decision I was like I don't know
why I'm pushing this so hard to be like
everyone who's got five million dollars
for a future that's not that's not how I
work I've never worked well that way
I've done a thousand bit of film as a
thousand times better because I've had
the time to craft it in sections i mean
the wildest sudden my head and being
honest yourself i guess is like being
like or not like and that was great like
or not we can't compete these people
like there's no way i can compete with
the expendables to this weekend no what
no one that means semester stallone i
mean just you know just amazing
filmmaking i know but you just yeah i
mean it's just like it's a you know look
you look at it and you're like Holly
this movie is made for five million and
it's got a 25 million dollar marketing
budget just cram down your throat and so
I like that's what was that gets blown
way around as I don't like that approach
that you guys are doing it's like I'm
roll it ok I'm not I'm not the dark
knight rises no yellow is not half the
countries that way
film but there is an audience at how I
get to it I get with that the best way I
can bob and weave so using a lot of
boxing metaphors this evening apparently
that's exactly I think a lot of what
hurts you know to some degree I think
there's a sort of curse when it comes to
film festivals because so many
filmmakers think that third film is the
one that's going to get into Sundance
you know like we all have this thing of
just like no no no no no this film is
getting into Sundance and I think I
think we all kind of set ourselves up so
we kind of had you kind of had to fight
that off and just release it and be like
you know what you know maybe our film
isn't good enough for the film festival
circuit you know knows no yes it's hard
to say but no but we know there's a
little bit of audience work and then
Lilith yeah you know so that that's kind
of where we're coming from in a world to
like words kind of just like you know
asses in seats type of thing and it's
like I mean you know sometimes it's like
all right so there's a hundred films or
60 films and Sundance and you start to
realize we break it down well you know
the people that have been back to you
know the crew the Sun Dance Crew it's
anyone with been in Sundance over the
last few years you know at least 30 of
them are making a film this year and
then you have the next thing and this
and into something that this person
talked to and I'd like to think maybe
I'm just doing this to make myself feel
better or something but I at the end of
the day I think there's like two films
that no one's ever heard of that they
like watched on anybody you know like
yeah this won't like knowing like
there's just after all said and done I
don't think there's that many that are
just like they find at the bottom of the
submissions power like wow what a jam I
mean I think that they've made it their
business to calculate very imprecision
because they're a corporation what their
brand is and and I think as filmmakers
like I just talked to something that is
like I put it in I'll put it on putting
blackberry to it it's like a lottery
ticket you got to be in it to win it I
guess I mean you have to be like it is a
place where people go and then all of a
sudden looking at something they never
looked at before and that's what it
should be but I don't think that we
should be beating ourselves up to the
point when we don't get into it that
were like
I had a filmmaker friend just like I'm
worthless and saying man you're
not worthless this is this one festival
then I know that year the curator didn't
go for that year that was not the plan
for that it's just like instead of just
like I mean that's also like you look as
a talk with you guys at seem like you
guys are the back same cut work so I
didn't make a sundance film this year
doesn't matter i'm still going to get it
out there and i'm still going make
another one i'm still going to be a
filmmaker lake and so maybe somehow that
separates some of the people that aren't
filmmakers in certain ways in the sense
it just did it to get more festival and
then they kind of didn't get into a
festival or someone and they disappear
with other people like why didn't get in
this year but you know i believe this
film on behind the stone let's get it
out there and let's keep Barney let's
keep moving let's keep making movies
like that's to me is what it is about
and it's not about the festival should
just be like that just like that little
cherry on top it like oh and we all get
to hang out together watch it at this
thing that's awesome like but the same
time you should all be excited just keep
making films that's and then that's me
maybe not all this but that's yeah so
what kids don't like you in high school
it doesn't mean you won't have friends
it just means you won't be a year
varsity team you just won't hang out
with those the cure oh fun
stuff not not not the scioscia is in the
jock so it doesn't mean that yeah you
still can't I've seen some of these
people those people at my like because
my parents live in the same town I'm
gonna go borrow those people no I that's
terrible say I mean yeah at the end of
the world is what you're saying and I
heard I just hate the end of the world
what is what I think the reason we all
like hold it as something at me want you
just want to do so bad is because it's
infectious because when you go like I
went to South by i went for filmmaker
magazine for micro budget conversation i
want to cover the festival and you know
as a smaller capacity but went to
experience it it was awesome i mean all
of us all i did all day was drink beer
and talk about movies and super then
amazing I mean that's the best thing I
mean for anyone who likes movies it's
it's awesome and so I think we just all
want to be hanging out together making
films you know we just have to learn
that sometimes we can do that through
our films and sometimes we don't and
sometimes we were there to learn and
sometimes we're going to show and also I
think sometimes we also have to learn
that there are a lot of people in this
world whether they're selling insurance
or they're making films they want to be
the cool kids table and that's fine and
that's totally fine but all I need to
get to is make I'm making another movie
and I like I think that the coolest
folks are the folks also at that table
we're all at the tape world the kids
table making movies in there there's
someone with table how cool they are
anyways that's that's a tangent and a
half but you know and I think what's
going to be interesting with what we're
doing is no since we did bypass film
festivals and since they do have all the
requirements that have interesting to
see after this run if we're able to
create enough excitement enough buzz you
know will they come knocking you know
are those two opportunities we're going
to want to pursue you know yeah we
really don't know what's what sort of on
the horizon with all this so that should
be another sort of interesting component
I guess be ecstatic yeah I mean they
take like another thing that could come
from it and another you could spend
another portion of you know like another
part two in a whole nother realm and
that might be awesome I mean that's you
get to have this interaction with folks
online and then you get to go right
there in the theater with them and then
I mean you know I think it's all gravy
at this point like I think anything you
do beyond making some money at it and
having a conversation is just it's just
awesome and the way no matter how we
like this is awesome no matter how many
times you can just talk with other
people that's am I thinking that's
that's a lot of fun so I think you guys
just made a conversation starter as we
do and you'll just kind of keep the
conversation going and then
okay to go other places whether people
want to talk about so ya gotta make the
next one next phone yeah it's like look
look at how you know if this works I
don't know we'll see but yeah I said the
same thing it's like okay now you can
just do something else yeah how three
years behind our computers sweaty
computer oh it's crazy the amount of
time that um you know just just how
infrequent you actually get you know at
that time you know when you're actually
making the film you really have to
cherish it because it seems to happen so
infrequently you know so you spend so
much of your time doing all this stuff
that you know you know sending emails
and then promoting and marketing and all
this other stuff so it's just like that
time we actually get to creating craft
is really awesome you know and certainly
certainly we missed that part of the
process you know when you want you just
like tweaking scenes and doing that
vivid post-production I don't know like
this is it this is something about being
on set being live and it sort of
creating in the moment which is really
awesome that's about the time to church
yeah that's yeah okay oh no yeah just
just being behind a computer I mean so
much of my day is just sending emails
out like I remember we interviewed this
one filmmaker omana Krauss she did this
movie called stripped down and this was
when we were new doing film courage and
she said so much of it looks glamorous
what she was doing but she said so much
of it is not glamorous at all and I get
I really do but it but anyway go ahead
hyjal no no you're right man interested
yet I mean a lot of it is is just
sitting in my living room haven't
showered yet running email from your
yeah let me yet sometimes just it's just
it's a slog but I mean it's upon this
log I like free for everyone's like a
little like pre-production I love it a
little like being like okay now how am I
get aid be to see now I'm going to be
everyone there we r they going to sleep
Martha Rodgers people do a motion for
this correct that just produced poems
but um álbum Sanders hmm all right you
like problem solving I do yeah I do I
think it's I think it's something that
I get mad when someone asked me to solve
a problem it's too easy it just dies we
not what I could probably already solved
or told someone and then they've solved
it and then they don't remember and I
not very good teacher I'll be quite up
Frank and honest i'm just not like I'm
just like I told you to do this
yesterday google it that's me but either
here over there I'm not it's interesting
you because you have never leave you
women you have a s for Tony Scott right
is that why you're wearing your shirt oh
this right here and it's I'm sorry this
is my mom actually it's from san diego
and b fest oh i thought it was for like
20 scotch or concern jumping off the
bridge in your town so that work no will
give it up no further a go yeah give him
some trucks but no time and it's really
a tragic story it's one that's just hit
us hard and we heard him maybe he got to
do that's what you were taught that in
your time I mean he got to do it like
and he's that's the best I mean like you
knew those you know those brothers I
mean you know that like they love doing
it and that's what they're meant to do I
guess it's what that was a weird long
way around and try to none of your shirt
and but try to tie that all and somehow
but good not me I think that you could
tell that he loved making movies and you
could tell that it's part of their DNA
and I think it's I think it's incredibly
it's the best thing in the world man to
be on set to be doing it to be to be
there and I think that we just have to
realize it like it's like you know it's
like I met up mr. metaphor it's like
having sex and then actually having a
baby maybe made me a little bit like it
was good for that time you were doing it
but then there's always oh you're
going to deal with the tail metaphor to
tell my wife just snickered in the other
room get food no it's okay no maybe like
it yeah it's just an agreement it's like
you're three weeks you're just like in
heaven and then it's like to
isn't just like oh I gotta do that all
right I still love it I still look I'm
going to do this you know I don't know
if you haven't you any more thoughts or
questions for us John but we want to
thank you okay take your time out
chatting with us talking talking about
your prob you know your confidence your
thing is live can you tell us tell us
the name don't tell us tell us how we
can find it sure it I mean it's obvious
I'm Kickstarter i'm trying to think the
it's 10 it's white creek feature film
but i think its kickstarter com /
projects / john w yo / white dash
creeped out featured don't think it is i
know right like that's kind of sick that
I know that like just the Holy oh yeah
i've been i've been pasting a lot it
crazy but yeah it's that that's what it
is right there we're gonna try to link
up right on the screen so people go and
check that out with the economy this
video cool cool and I get it um I gotta
go as you send some stuff up in the next
few weeks too because much of the film
and stuff going to get you guys out
there as much as whatever I can that's a
funny thing is that it's so my friend
who it was something that is like front
of my came in the new album and I like
totally was like this I was amazing and
i put on my my forget who was was just
like what are you doing you have a
campaigner I'm like heaven I wouldn't be
no that's ridiculous i like this album
I'm not gonna I mean like if people get
sick a here like my campaign my campaign
mom and like this is awesome yeah so I
get back and forth and and then I guess
I'm going to talk with Lucas and I'm
going to work with him to try to make
some sort of telephone thing happen I
guess yeah we love East nor can I don't
know exact what he's going to do with it
I don't know what his his thoughts are
on the whole thing but I know he's
trying his best oh and this would be for
what the last 48 hours like the next two
days or I think so yeah like a Thursday
Friday full-on thing I don't know
talk to more and I don't want to design
those out there I don't want to like
promise or or say something I don't know
about but I know it was on his mind so
awesome all right you know we'll
definitely be participating um you know
committed to seeing jacket received this
goal and so we have a busy day tomorrow
on Wednesday but then we're going to be
full steam ahead thursday friday we're
going to see him through the finish line
so well looking forward to that moment
so it's actually been it's actually miss
group of relief on us to kind of take
take our heads off our own campaign and
just put that energy into someone else I
don't know there's a second there's
something spiritual there's something
karmic about it and it's actually
there's a little bit of a weight off our
shoulders right now and then went back
to the grind for the last two weeks and
see if we can make some you know turn
some heads and increase more excitement
sure I mean that's the best thing about
it I mean the vet this and that and you
guys help them out that's the that's
like I said and that's that's the reason
why we're rocking rock stars and that's
reason why we do this the more fun you
know like that's that's the best thing
about it that's the headstock so not
money there's the ethos the stuff we're
helping each other bit so that's awesome
alright and be fun thank you so much for
talking and I'm it was funny because
like we got to meet at Marty's thing but
we were like you guys had a scoot and I
had a scoot and I was from out of town
and we were like but it was finally we
got to sit down and just chill on top
yeah fine I was really fun going out to
quinnipiac 04 though we haven't fully
mentioned this real quick this we did a
funny discussion at Quinnipiac
University go Marty Leigh no setup by
our game oh so yeah that was awesome no
we're like we're like who's this guy
that's like he really knows probably
know Wow ecology window closes oh oh oh
he's friends and my little I was like
wow this guy could teach this panel why
is he attending it there and then how
did you tell me like who John well I
forget like I guess you shook hands or
something yeah yeah we talked after
thank you like college student I was
drawn from from yeah yeah
oh you are you a college here's like no
no no but maybe yeah maybe I should have
gone a corner with how you see what I
think I yak great beautiful ghost worn
on top of the elbow hey ok sir no that's
it we're wrapping up here you really you
know enjoyed the conversation with Lucas
tell them we say I'm ho towards we're
gonna keep pushing Jack and see this
thing through okay yeah yeah meet me as
well so let's do it and i'll talk to you
guys soon thank you sorry see you online
soon all right thank you know kids bias